[Applause]
yo
i know everybody has heard the wet ass
[ __ ] sawing that
whap cardi b meg the stallion what y'all
haven't heard is the remix
i don't even know how they put out a
remix so fast this [ __ ] is straight fire
right i know everybody's bopping to the
song but this remix
is unbelievable i don't even know how
they got this dude
on the song i mean it's absolutely
incredible
just play it out hit that [ __ ] let's go
let's vlog to start this podcast man
let's vibe
ready you ready oh i'm ready for this
house there's [ __ ] in this house hey
what is in this house uh there's some
horses in this house
hold up i said certified freak seven
days a week oh wet ass
p-word
yeah you even with some wet ass p word
people okay female genitalia
he wants female genitals pause that
that's too much eating yo autistic adam
smith that's ben shapiro right there
hold on give us a little more of that
shapiro come on you nerd
tell us about that wet ass p-word for
this wet ass keyword
give me everything you got for this wet
ass p word
beat it up inward catch a charge extra
large and extra hard
with this p word right in your face
swipe your nose like a credit card
oh [ __ ] he said nose and credit card in
the same
yo oh my god bro
keep it hey keep it going inside it's
too crazy oh he got more
kegel well it's inside spit in my mouth
look in my eyes
this p word is wet come take a dive
don't do it it continues
uh along these lines oh and it gets
significantly it's significantly more
vulgar what
yo you know he got more in the chamber
was that out
what's that out i want to see hold on
hold on hold on hold on i want to see
the ball get y'all want to see the
bulgarian
honestly you all want to see the ball
gertie all right
hey listen ben tuck that yarmulke in
your back pocket and drop this second
verse let's go with the vulgarity
you really ain't never gonna f him for a
thing he already made his mind up before
he
came now get your boots and your coat
for this wet ass p-word
oh my god just to kiss me on this wet
ass right so
this is d guys guys this this is what
feminists fought for
this is what the feminist movement was
all about stop
whoa i mean bro whoa meg and cardi got
to watch out yo
yeah that [ __ ] is yo megan carty gotta
watch out let go
honestly ben might have the wettest
[ __ ] on you
let me yeah do y'all think that [ __ ]
was wet oh my god
no he sounds like a p word
son that's the wet ass [ __ ] right there
bro
that's different yo probably sliding off
his chair when he was rapping real talk
do you think it's possible do you think
it's possible
that it that there is truth to this
the verses are so fire that even ben
shapiro
could read it and it's still hot
i mean clearly yeah i wasn't getting as
high and heavy as when cardi and meg
were rapping
but i will say it had it had me feeling
the type of weight oh i beg to differ
i mean this is the illest remix i've
heard really my dick moved
all acapella oh man acapella like that
p word uh like i was playing it from my
laptop but i have the visual of ben
here oh my gosh i'm straight wood right
now different
guys look away smooth ass face look away
oh man i wish he did a whole album
he might need who else would you put on
there what other songs would you like to
see ben share a remix
my neck my back oh your keyword and your
c word yeah
yo wanted to be so many words that he
just can't even say the words
real talk yeah that would be the ideal
yin yang twain's whisper in your ear
now we're talking hey little mother
allow me to whisper in your ear
wait till you see my oh
fire yo um guys we need to get to the
bottom something very important
okay who has the wettest ass [ __ ]
in that video my gut my gut is cardi
cardi alex i don't know why i'm gonna go
meg
meg yeah i say you say meg yep
interesting party kind of grows me i'll
be honest a little bit no no i'm not
talking about the hottest yeah it's not
who's the hottest
it's who has the wettest ass [ __ ] and
what's very interesting about this
discussion i think meg still hurts
suppose he's the wettest the ass
possible not related to looks neither of
you guys
know what weapon is i want to clarify
that oh wait a minute you guys have
fingered girls before
yeah that aren't your girlfriends yeah
so you have technically
felt other [ __ ] okay so you would
know
you wouldn't know if your current one is
wetter or
drier than the other [ __ ] you
fingered
i would okay right okay good okay just
making sure that we can have this
discussion
right i
what what else i didn't know that they
figured
women before yeah i've been given
[ __ ] that come hither yo
what's up [ __ ] that guy's out here
fingering him bro
[ __ ] come get that come together [ __ ]
i know that shout out to you
yeah bro i was killing it out here
i think i think cardi's got the wettest
[ __ ]
i agree i'm with you on cardi's got the
wettest [ __ ]
cause everything about her is wet like
even when she talks
moist mouth it's moist mouth there's
right it's like everything is super wet
about her yeah
i'm assuming wettest [ __ ] is cardi
without a doubt wettest [ __ ]
meg the stallion might have a deck
so we're not sure based on that
if the [ __ ] is wet megan maggie seems
too big
it's just moisture's going everywhere
else
there's a lot of different places for
the moisture there's a lot of different
places where the moisture go
it could be you know all throughout her
body it could be like healing gunshot
wounds it's doing a lot
yes yes i agree i think i'm going to
have to go cardi
now what i may say
i heard the theory that i thought that
she was an actual horse so he shot her
in the leg
oh man
that's what i have i literally have to
keep that i literally
you know i literally thought this is
what i was told they were having sex
and then and all of a sudden uh tori
just heard
and and then just popped up he started
bucking off
that's what i heard buckingham perfect
[ __ ]
[ __ ] off this part before she chopped
off your horse because of her ass he got
the ass of a stallion stallion
obviously everyone ah there it is
also horses got wet [ __ ] you ever seen
how big horse dicks are oh they got to
be wet
you got to be super duper wet to get
that big horse stick in there that's why
i say meg probably has the wettest
position you think yeah huh
mark yeah i agree
why do y'all think that i don't
understand why you all think
meg got the wettest [ __ ] i don't
understand it uh cardi seems like
she's dried up she's haggard what whoa
little i don't cardi grows me out i
don't know why i'm not saying
i said i just trying this with
attractiveness
[ __ ] wetness doesn't have to do with
like what she knows about like
skateboarding
just [ __ ] wetness exists within its own
department
you can support the fed and still have a
wet [ __ ] she hates you she's been
stripping for years and years and years
yeah that's why i feel like it's like
it's just that's her gift
oh do you think that she's so
detached from doesn't the well dry up
after kids i don't think [ __ ] gets
oh maybe it does i think the world's
dried up meg meg is young
she's a stallion you don't know her age
i think they're both young no she's 26
cardi's like 30 something no she's she's
old we're old like 36.
you